Herr Mölling wie schätzen Sie die
aktuelle Situation an der Front ein na
ich glaube wir dürfen uns auf keinen
Fall in einer Art von von Ruhe wiegen
weder durch die Annahme dass diese
Offensive scheitt das ist ja die das
eine was jetzt sozusagen die der die
neue Diskussion ist oder auf der anderen
Seite Leute die sagen wir hätten es mit
einem Pat zu tun insbesondere mit von
einer patsituation kann man nicht
sprechen denn der Begriff des patslicht
nah dass wir am Ende eines Spiels werden
wie viele Züge sowohl Russland als auch
die Ukraine noch machen können
in diesen in den kommenden Monaten das
wird sich zeigen hängt aber im
Wesentlichen von der Hilfe des Westens
ab und auf der anderen Seite von der
Hilfe die Russland von seinen Partnern
also dem Iran und auch Nordkorea bekommt
auf diese Hilfen sowohl für die eine als
auch für die andere Seite werden wir
später noch eingehen es gibt direkt aus
dem Chat Fragen von Mario was muss
passieren dass die aktuelle russische
Druckphase überwunden und eine neue
Phase des Krieges eingeleitet wird also
es gibt ja Stimmen die sagen dass SE
Russland seine Kräfte für den Moment
ausgereizt hat sehen Sie da Hinweise
ähm natürlich gibt's immer wieder
Hinweise die darauf hindeuten aber wir
sehen ja gleichzeitig auch dass Russland
seine Kapazitäten was die materielle
Durchhaltefähigkeit also die Industrie
angeht gestärkt hat und wir gehen
zurzeit auch davon aus dass Russland im
Zweifelsfalle keinen Problem hat oder
weniger Probleme hat neue Soldaten zu
gewinnen auch da ist Russland kreativ
gewesen ich ich glaube der größte Fehler
den wir machen können ist zu glauben
dass das was gestern und vorgestern in
der letzten Woche Stand der Dinge
gewesen ist dass das morgen und
übermorgen auch so ist der Krieg hat
immer wieder Überraschungen gezeigt gute
oder schlechte für die Ukraine
m und ich glaube darauf sollte man nicht
vertrauen das was die Ukraine braucht
und das wissen wir vom ersten Tage an
ist Unterstützung der Eindruck des
ersten Kriegsjahres dass die Ukraine
ganz leicht ganz viel Gelände
zurückgewinnen kann ist sicherlich ein
Ausdruck davon gewesen oder ein
Startpunkt gewesen von dem jetzt
Enttäuschung sich breit macht aber es
gehört immer wieder mit dazu dass diese
Enttäuschung auch zum Teil zum großen
Teil durch den Westen selber produziert
ist denn er ist nicht nur Beobachter er
ist aktiver Akteur denn er unterstützt
die Ukraine und das was wir in den
letzten 6 Monaten nicht geliefert haben
hat die Situation jetzt in der Ukraine
mit bestimmt es gibt noch eine zweite
Frage aus dem Chat könnte es
möglicherweise die Absicht der Ukraine
bzw des Westens sein dass die Ukrain
absichtlich in ein er defensiven
Position verbleibt um die russischen
Streitkräfte zu
erschöpfen ich glaube da muss man sehr
stark unterscheiden zwischen einer eher
taktischen Perspektive was passiert da
gerade vor Ort natürlich hat die Ukraine
gerade gar keine Kräfte um überhaupt in
irgendeiner Offensive zu gehen das hat
ja auch was mit dem Gelände zu tun in
der Situation der man ist aber vor allen
Dingen auch mit der Versorgung mit
Munition und der Ausbildung dem
Ausbildungsstand der eigenen Truppen da
ist es zurzeit sicherlich sinnvoller für
die Ukraine in der Defensive zu bleiben
und dann eben in der Tat die russischen
Angriffe zurückzuschlagen das ist
einfacher aber hierfür da sind ja in den
letzten Tagen auch Zahlen veröffentlicht
worden fehlt der Ukraine tatsächlich
effektiv mehr
Artilleriemunition um die eigenen Leute
auch zu schützen um eben diese Angriffe
sicher zurückzuschlagen aus der Distanz
und nicht durch eigene infantriekräfte
möglicherweise zurückzuschlagen und da
sind die Handlungsoptionen tatsächlich
geringer geworden für die Ukraine sie
hat keine andere Wahl als sich zu
verteidigen denn wenn sie aufgeben würde
würde das den Tod für viele andere
Ukrainer bedeuten nicht nur die Aufgabe
von Land sondern vor allen Dingen von
Menschen aber die Möglichkeiten die wir
der Ukraine geben die sind radikal
gesunken neue Waffen und
munitionslieferungen gerade eher
schwierig und gleichzeitig hören wir aus
Kiev dass die ukrainische Flugabwehr
gezielt Raketen durchlassen muss wie
schätzen Sie die Rolle der USA ein und
die der
Europäer ja ich Glauber hat das
eigentlich schon sehr schön die
arbeitszahlung rieben die Amerikaner
sind
unverzichtbar für die militärischen
Güter weil sie sie einfach herstellen
und in einer viel größeren Zahlen noch
verfügbar haben als die Europäer das
haben die Europäer sind auf der anderen
Seite die eueopäer auf der anderen Seite
kümmern sich um viel um die Dinge die
das tägliche Leben sicherstellen in der
Ukraine also alles das was nicht
militärisch ist dafür sind sie
essentiell und wenn einer dieser Pfeiler
wegbricht dann ist das eine dramatische
Situation
ähm gut ein paar farbsprengsel paar
positive Botschaften zu haben aber
insgesamt muss man sagen
laufen wir hier in eine Situation hinein
die sich eigentlich keiner wünschen kann
in Europa
die sehr dramatisch ist für die Ukraine
aber auch für für Gesamteuropa was das
Signal an Russland angeht dass man im
Grunde genommen weiter auf Zeit spielen
kann ja und der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hat ja auch heute gesagt also
dass das Zögern des Westens eben Putin
auch stärker machen würde würden Sie dem
zustimmen ja absolut also wir sehen ja
ja ähm dass Putin im Grunde keine
Verhandlungsbereitschaft hat und er
deutlich nachgelegt hat in den letzten
Wochen äh als die die Erfolge auf der
einen Seite an der Front ä größer
geworden sind und auf der anderen Seite
auch er Zuversicht im Rahmen seiner
präsidentschafts Kandidatur ausstrahlen
wollte wo hier klar gemacht worden ist
es gibt keinen Grund zu verhandeln und
in der Tat zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt und
auch in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
sehe ich keinen Grund warum Putin
tatsächlich in Verhandlungen eintreten
sollte er kann abwarten was mit den
US-Wahlen passiert und für ihn wäre ein
zu frühes Ende dieses Krieges auch
schlecht weil er dann tatsächlich
sozusagen einen Tag der Abrechnung haben
würde er braucht den Krieg quasi um am
Leben zu bleiben es ist ein
Ausnahmezustand der viel rechtfertigt
und der im Grunde genommen ihn auch
politisch zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt am
Leben hält ich würde gern ein paar
Fragen aus dem Chat mit ihnen durchgehen
Amadeus fragt was müsste die westliche
Rüstungsindustrie tun um die Ukraine in
die Lage zu versetzen den Krieg gewinnen
zu können und was werden die spürbaren
Auswirkungen für die Bevölkerung ja die
Rüstungsindustrie kann erst tätig werden
wenn die Staaten das Geld zur Verfügung
stellen und das ist glaube ich der
wichtigste Punkt es wäre sehr viel mehr
möglich ich habe mich heute noch mal
intensiv erkundigt es gibt Kapazitäten
die aber letztendlich nicht abgerufen
werden durch die Europäer durch die
Europäische Union auch nicht oderch die
Staaten der Europäischen Union es sind
die Mitgliedstaaten die hier am Drücker
sind die die Möglichkeiten haben wir
haben immer noch Munition die
offensichtlich in hohem Maße ins Ausland
geht und nicht in die Ukraine und auch
nicht für die eigenen Arsenale in Europa
genutzt wird ich glaube hier muss man
anfangen tatsächlich kreativ zu werden
auf der einen Seite nämlich eine Art von
munitionsringtausch zu machen es gibt
munitionslieferanten die wollen nicht in
die Ukraine liefern die können aber in
nach Europa liefern das heißt hier
könnte man diese Munition aufkaufen und
dann die eigene Munition in die Ukraine
liefern ähm auf der anderen Seite sehen
wir dass die Frage immer stärker wird
ersetzen möglicherweise kleinst droh
auch
Artilleriemunition nicht komplett aber
in gewissen Teilen möglicherweise muss
man hier flexibler denken was sozusagen
die Mittel sind die man einsetzt aber
alles das sind tatsächlich Krisen
Wahlmöglichkeiten in die man nicht hätte
kommen müssen wenn man frühzeitig
gehandelt hätte der munitionsbedarf war
klar dass der kommen wird und das heißt
auch für die Zukunft ist die Frage das
was wir jetzt tun auch was wir nicht tun
wird bestimmen was in SE Monaten oder
auch in zwei Monaten in der Ukraine
passiert oder auch nicht passiert das
ist ein Teil unserer Verantwortung denn
wir können handeln und wenn wir es nicht
tun dann laden wir diesen Teil der
Verantwortung auf uns es gibt noch eine
weitere Frage kann Deutschland von den
USA Waffen kaufen und an die Ukraine
weitergeben genau das wäre auch noch
eine Möglichkeit
dass man die USA hat ihre Produktion im
Bereich der der Munition auch der Waffen
teilweise hochgefahren dass man versucht
einen Deal nur mit der Exekutive zu
machen zu sagen nicht die Ukraine kauft
das aber wir kaufen dieses Theme und
geben Sie dann dann weiter das ist eine
Frage von Exportkontrolle das wäre
möglicherweise ohne die Involvierung
größerer Teile der des
Repräsentantenhaus und des Kongresses zu
machen also wie gesagt das ist ein Teil
der Kreativität da ist glaube ich
zurzeit viel möglich die Europäer haben
sich zum Teil selber Handschellen
angelegt weil sie gesagt haben
europäisches Geld nur für europäische
Rüstungsproduktion insbesondere
Frankreich ist da nach vorne geprescht
ich glaube dass solche Arten von
Rücksichtnahme auf äh die eigene
Industrie kein Schlüssel dafür ist um
europäische Sicherheit herzustellen denn
darum geht es hier im Grunde genommen
die Ukraine kämpft zur Zeit im Grunde
genommen dafür dass sich Europa und wir
hier zurzeit einigermaßen sicher fühlen
können
da kann man glaube ich solche Petitessen
beiseite lassen der grünenpitiker Anton
Hofreiter hat gesagt dass er es bizarr
findet dass der Kanzler bereit ist
Saudi-Arabien Kampfjets zu liefern aber
der Ukraine wichtige Waffen verweigere
ist das jetzt Äpfel mit Birnen
verglichen oder hat er dann ein Punkt ja
vergleichen kann man alles aber
gleichsetzen nicht ich glaube ich würde
es nicht gleichsetzen die Frage von Taus
aber auch von vielen anderen
Waffensystemen die nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit sind aber die z.B zu
drohnenabwehr genutzt werden Drohnen
sind das kommende Thema sowohl auf der
ukrainischen als auch auf der russischen
Seite darüber spricht niemand das ist
offensich zu komplex das sind alles
Dinge die wir hätten schon anfangen
können zu produzieren die wir vielleicht
schneller produzieren können wenn wir
auch unsere eigenen Vorschriften
dementsprechend anpassen
da muss man nicht den Vergleich mit
Saudi-Arabien wagen weil das viel
komplexer ist die Lage damit zu
vergleichen ähm die Lieferung an die
Ukraine sind sozusagen eine Sache für
sich die unabhängig davon stehen und die
unabhängig davon für die Sicherheit
Europas notwendig sind jetzt äh soll
Russland ja auch ballistische Raketen
aus nordkoreanischer Produktion
eingesetzt haben m könnte das der Anfang
von größeren Waffenlieferungen aus
Nordkorea sein das kann ich nicht
abschätzen aber es zeigt auf einer
anderen Ebene dass Russland ebeno
kreativ ist und seine Partnerschaften
nutzt genauso wie die Ukraine das
versucht zu tun und im grundeommen sein
schrumpfendes Arsenal nicht
ausschlaggebend dafür ist dass es nicht
mehr kampffähig ist das muss man sich
einfach glaube ich vor Augen führen ja
waren zwei Staaten die tatsächlich einem
der mindestens der eine Staat in einem
existentiellen Kampf sind putin ist für
sich sicherlich auch in einem
existentiellen Kampf das heißt es werden
alle Möglichkeiten genutzt
die da sind und das
jetzt Nordkorea stärker mit reing zogen
wird zumindest als Lieferant ist
ist nur eine logische Konsequenz daraus
dass Russland eigene Probleme hat in der
Herstellung der Raketen das bedeutet
aber für uns dass man eben nicht
zugucken kann sondern dass man versuchen
muss die Sanktionen immer wieder
nachzuschärfen das ist ein Katz und
Mausspiel das an vielen Fronten abläuft
zu glauben eine Maßnahme würde
ausreichen hat mit einer Realität des
Krieges überhaupt nicht zu tun der sich
ständig weiterentwickelt sven hat auf
Facebook noch mal eine Frage in Bezug zu
den waffenliefer aus Nordkorea was kann
denn der Westen tun um die Unterstützer
Russlands also in Klammern schreibt der
China Iran Nordkorea von Russland
abbrücken zu lassen ich glaube dass die
überzeugungsmöglichkeiten da relativ
gering sind ein Teil der Regime ist ja
bereits
geächtet da kann man sicherlich hier und
da noch mal versuchen das zu machen ich
glaube hier geht's darum dass wir wir
haben direkte Möglichkeiten der
Unterstützung die wir hochfahren können
die Möglichkeiten im Bereich der
Munition sind aus meiner Sicht noch
nicht ausgereizt hier gibt's noch
Möglichkeiten die Frage ist dann immer
ist man bereit das Geld dafür in die
Hand zu nehmen und da sehen wir
natürlich nicht nur in Berlin sondern
auch in anderen Ländern aber gerade auch
in Berlin also Thema Notlage und
Schuldenbremse dass wir eben nicht
bereit sind über den Tellerrand unserer
Normallage der letzten Jahre hinausz
gucken und zu verstehen dass wir es mit
dem größten Krieg in Europa seit 70
Jahren zu tun haben und dass er sich
nicht an normale Haushaltsregeln des
Deutschen Bundestages und der
Bundesregierung hält Rom fragt auf
Youtube müss nicht auch bald mal ein
Umdenken bezüglich militärischer Ziele
in Russland erfolgen die Ukraine muss
sich zerschießen lassen schreibt er und
darf mit gelieferten Waffen sich nicht
wehren das Umdenken ist wahrscheinlich
eher jetzt nicht für Russland gedacht
sondern für für andere
Länder ich kann die oder so würde ich es
interpretieren die Ohnmacht die in der
Frage drinne steht verstehen wir sehen
dass die Realität seit zi Jahren ist
dass dieses Umdenken hier nicht
stattfindet und das ist sicherlich sehr
traurig weil wir gleichzeitig auch keine
klare Aussage darüber haben was wir denn
tatsächlich erreichen wollen das fehlt
seit zwei Jahren man mauschelt sich im
Grunde genommen so durch wie es
irgendwie geht aber tatsächlich ist der
Preis den wir DAF langfristig oder sogar
nur mittelfristig Zahlen tatsächlich ein
höheres Risiko für die Sicherheit in
Europa die Sicherheit nimmt dadurch ab
einfach auch sie hatten es zwischendurch
schon gesagt Putin fühlt sich in seiner
Sichtweise auf den Westen bestärkt dass
er nicht stark handungsfähig ist und
nicht bereit ist zum in
anführungstrichen Äußersten zu gehen
also die Ukraine mit extremen Maßnahmen
zu unterstützen und dass damit eine
Schwäche des Westens zu Tage tritt die
man auch in Zukunft weiter ausnutzen
wird um einfach seine Einfluss wieder
stärker in Richtung Osteuropa
auszudehnen und damit die Europäische
Union und die NATO zu schwächen es gibt
noch eine weitere Frage von Erik wann
werden in großem Umfang Mittel zur
elektronischen Kriegsführung geliefert
und warum wird das bisher nicht gemacht
ähm also man muss fairerweise sagen
einen Teil der Lieferung äh davon
erfahren wir Gott sei Dank nichts aber
Deutschland gehört auch nicht zu den
Ländern das besonders führend ist in all
diesen Bereichen
ist die klassischer Bereich der
insgesamt im Westen vernachlässigt
worden ist ich glaube die Frage ist eher
wann schalten wir um und verstehen dass
wir zumindest in gewissen Teilen in
diesem Krieg den wir zurzeit sehen auch
taktische Formen des Krieges sehen mit
denen wir in Zukunft konfrontiert sein
werden wenn wir sehen dass
offensichtlich drohen die nicht zu uns
gehören über unseren Übungsplätzen
fliegen und wir nicht in der Lage sind
die zu bekämpfen dann ist das in der Tat
ein ohnmachtszeugnis und wenn wir das
hier schon nicht schaffen schaffen wir
es in der Ukraine auch nicht insgesamt
sehen wir mit unserer eigenen Sicherheit
ziemlich löcherig aus ähm ich kann nur
sagen ich hoffe dass wir relativ schnell
in diesem Bereich den Hebel umschalten
ähm ob es eine weitere Task Force ist
dazu weiß ich nicht tatsächlich glaube
ich dass die Industrie in der Lage ist
das zu liefern es bleibt dabei
Industrie kann nur dann handeln wenn der
Staat handelt und bereit ist zu handeln
ansonsten ist wieder das Geld da noch
sind die sind die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen dafür geschaffen dass
in Deutschland oder in Europa dazu
gehandelt werden kann es gibt h im Chat
auch noch Fragen zur Position Russlands
zur aktuellen Stärke oder eben Schwäche
z.B erkennt man schon an gewissen
Ansätzen dass Russland den Krieg bereits
strategisch verloren hat oder sind
nordkoreanisch koreanische Lieferung
nicht eigentlich ein Zeichen dafür dass
die russische Armee am schwächeln ist
ähm ich glaube man kann diese Fragen
immer nur sagen für ein gewissen
Zeitraum beantworten oder wir haben im
gommen zwei Zeiträume wir haben Wettlauf
so muss man es glaube ich beschreiben
auf der ukrainischen auf der russischen
Seite nicht nur was den die Front angeht
sondern die Frage wie kriege ich
Material an die Front wie schnell kriege
ich Soldaten ausgebildet alles das was
ich letztendlich zum Kämpfen brauche
verläuft mit unterschiedlichen
Zeitlinien ähm und des deswegen geht's
auch dar drum zu welchem Zeitpunkt Dinge
zur Verfügung stehen wenn wir warten mit
der Lieferung von langreichweitigen
Raketen also z.B Taurus bis 2025 2026
dann ist die kerchbrücke möglicherweise
nicht mehr so wichtig dann ist die
Lieferung auch nicht mehr so relevant
das heißt also der Zeitpunkt einer
solchen Lieferung von von Waffensystemen
kann schon entscheidend sein dass
Russland
Anzeichen der Schwäche zeigt ist das
andere Extrem zu der Diskussion rund um
das Pad das wir jetzt immer wieder so
hören beides sind wie gesagt extreme
darauf würde ich mich nicht verlassen
das kann sich das sind Momentaufnahmen
die sich einfach verändern können
Russland ähm hat sich tatsächlich
umgestellt auf diesen Krieg der Krieg
ist etwas was einen wesentlichen Teil
des Staates bestimmt weil es die
Machtstrukturen in Russland tatsächlich
am Leben erhält es kann sich keiner in
diese Machtstrukturen zurzeit leisten
dass dieser Krieg aufhört deswegen gibt
es auch da quasi eine Form von von
Überlebenskampf der ist ganz anders als
der den die Ukraine kämpfen muss
aber es gibt aus beiden sichten heraus
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt keine keine
Position wo man sagen kann wir finden
eine Alternative auch weil man damit
rechnen muss zumindest aus ukrainischer
Sicht dass selbst wenn man jetzt sagen
würde wir sind bereit zu verhandeln
Russland erstens ist nicht
verhandlungsbereit und zweitens all das
was bei solchen Verhandlungen rauskäme
wäre wahrscheinlich das Papier nicht
wert auf das es geschrieben wird weil
Russland ja sich dadurch ausgezeichnet
hat in den letzten Jahren alle alle
Verträge zu brechen die irgendwo
Sicherheit in Europa hergestellt haben
vielleicht noch mal zum Thema
Verhandlungen der italienische
Verteidigungsminister hat heute davon
gesprochen dass jetzt an der Zeit sei
mit Diplomatie den Weg für einen Frieden
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine zu
ebnen es gibt auch namenhafte us-berater
die dann schon im Kanzleramt gehört
worden sein sollen die im endszenario
für den Krieg und auch Verhandlung
während des Krieges gefordert haben wie
schätzen Sie das ein gibt's da eine exit
Option also erstens es gibt ständig
diplomatische Initiativen es gibt auch
Verhandlungen wir haben gesehen dass es
einen großen Gefangenen Austausch
gegeben hat zwischen Russland der
Ukraine diese Verhandlung haben aber
Monate gedauert nur
um Soldaten auszutauschen jetzt muss man
sich vorstellen wie lange das
letztendlich dauern wird hier einen
einen sinnvollen ich will das Wort
Frieden gar nicht in die Hand nehmen
Waffenstillstand auszuhandeln und alles
das was hier an Vorschlägen immer wieder
kursiert kursiert nur unter dem
Vorschlag Verhandlungen verhandeln kann
man die Frage ist ob man ein Ergebnis
fixieren kann und ob irgendjemand glaubt
oder sicherstellen kann dass ein solches
Ergebnis von Verhandlungen auch am
nächsten Tag noch gilt wenn es nicht
mehr zum Vorteil Russland insbesondere
ist und diese Frage würde ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt mit Nein beantworten
aus der Erfahrung heraus und aus der
Logik heraus dass der Russland zurzeit
handelt ich werde gerne widerlegt aber
ich höre neben den Verhandlungen nichts
wie diese imgenommen abgesegnet werden
sollen und erstens das auf der anderen
Seite denn zu Verhandlungen gehören ja
immer zwei dass auf der anderen Seite
überhaupt Russland ernsthaft Platz
nehmen würde und sagen würde ja wir sind
bereit tatsächlich über signifikante
Dinge zu verhandeln die letzten Dinge
die als Vorbedingungen gestellt worden
sind ist im Grunde genommen eine
Abschaffung der ukrainischen Regierung
od Einsetzen eines marionettensystems
eine komplette Entwaffnung der
ukrainischen Armee also im Grunde
genommen die komplette Kapitulation
sind zurück zu dem Zeitpunkt wo wir 2022
schon gewesen sind Christian Mölling
viele Fragen beantwortet vielen Dank
dafür für ihre anal schönen Abend noch
tschüs danke